2018 saw the emergence of the
first hundred billion dollar man.
The idea of that much money is
enough to make your head spin,
but don't tell me you've never
dreamed about it. The question is,
what would you do? What could you
do? Would you buy the crown jewels,
a giant house or a private plane?
Would you make the world a better place?
Could you even live long enough
to spend it? This is what if,
and here's what you could
buy with $100 billion.
It seems like those with money are
often judged by how they use it.
Some people spend more than the cost
of a college education on a car,
and then the ro campaigns,
like the giving pledge that has seen
175 of the world's wealthiest people
pledging to donate the majority, they're
fortunate to charitable causes. So far,
the members of the giving pledge have
collectively promise more than $365
billion, but for a lot of us, it's
hard to quantify that type of money.
So to help put it all in perspective,
here are some of the things you
could buy with $100 billion.
You've been thinking about that dream
vacation for awhile and now you can
finally go wherever you want
for as long as you want.
But what does it mean to travel
in style? Well, for $100 billion,
you could buy around 250 Boeing
seven 40 sevens in other words,
establish your own private airline.
But if you're seriously
considering a kingly existence,
why not buy an entire country
with a GDP of $90 billion?
You could practically own Costa Rica,
and while you're busy turning
the world into a monopoly board,
why not add another game to your
collection with $100 billion?
You could furnish a real version of the
classic board game battleship with the
cost of to small fleets each with its
own aircraft carrier coming in at about
$50 billion.
It's up to you how much you want to spend
on fuel ammo and personnel with just
half of your fortune. You could buy
the world's largest royal domain,
the palace of Versailles with
its 700 rooms, 600 paintings,
400 sculptures, and
1400 fountains. In fact,
you'd still have enough leftover for
the White House, Buckingham Palace,
Saint Peter's Petersburg winter palace,
and Tokyo's Imperial Palace.
Or You could just buy the loof and
its contents for a modest 45 billion,
but if art isn't your thing,
how about sports?
With the average cost of an American
football franchise at $1 billion,
you can own every team in the national
football league and still have enough
leftover to buy all the teams
in Major League Baseball,
the National Hockey League and
the English Premiere League.
While you might call that a win win,
it's important to remember
that for some people,
a billion in the bank is not just a
reality, but a serious responsibility.
$100 is enough money to put roughly
757,000 students through American colleges
for four years.
You could triple America's
proposed foreign assistance
budget for 2019 offering
three times the amount of food medicine
and security to a wider range of
recipients in over 100 countries.
Considering that it would only cost an
estimated $60 million to save the Great
Barrier Reef.
Think how far $100 billion could take
us along the path of sustainable living
and environmental protection.
Of course,
we could always diversify and
tackle several world issues at once.
A team of some of the world's
top economists claim that
an annual investment of
$3 billion could reduce malnutrition in
the developing world by 36% saving over
100 million children from starvation
each year. On top of that,
an additional $2 billion every year
towards agricultural research and
development would not only
increase global food security,
but also protect biodiversity
and prevent deforestation.
These are trends that could only become
more cost effective as they continue to
be funded.
It may seem like a sad reality to consider
that money really does make the world
go round,
but that doesn't mean we have to think
selfishly put towards a good cause.
Money can make a world of difference.
Lifting people out of poverty
and stimulating growth,
education and innovation.
As long as enough people
remain willing to give back,
then we should all consider
ourselves fortunate. So how about it?
What would you do with $100 billion.